sorry my phone died it's nothing I'm
fine these allegations are completely
unfounded the company was not aware of
any wrongdoing I love you we are
anywhere from 10 to 200 lies a day and
we spent much of our history coming up
the ways to detect them from medieval
torture devices to polygraphs blood
pressure breathing monitors voice-stress
analyzers eye trackers infrared brain
scanners and even the 400-pound
electroencephalogram
but although such tools have worked
under certain circumstances most can be
fooled with enough preparation and none
are considered reliable enough to even
be admissible in court but what if the
problem is not with the techniques but
the underlying assumption that lying
Spurs physiological changes what if we
took a more direct approach using
communication science to analyze the
lies themselves on a psychological level
we lie partly to paint a better picture
of ourselves connecting our fantasies to
the person we wish we were rather than
the person we are but while our brain is
busy dreaming it's letting plenty of
signals slip by our conscious mind only
controls about five percent of our
cognitive function including
communication while the other 95 percent
occurs beyond our awareness and
according to the literature on reality
monitoring stories based on imagined
experiences are qualitatively different
from those based on real experiences
this suggests that creating a false
story about a personal topic takes work
and results in a different pattern of
language use a technology known as
linguistic text analysis has helped to
identify four such common patterns in
the subconscious language of deception
first Liars reference themselves less
when making deceptive statements they
write or talk more about others often
using the third person to distance and
disassociate themselves from their lie
which sounds more false absolutely no
party took place at this house or I
didn't host a party here second Liars
tend to be more negative because on a
subconscious level they feel guilty
about lying
for example a liar might say something
like sorry my stupid phone battery died
I hate that thing
third Liars typically explain events in
simple terms since our brains struggled
to build a complex lie judgment and
evaluation are complex things for our
brains to compute as a US president once
famously insisted I did not have sexual
relations with that woman and finally
even though Liars keep descriptions
simple they tend to use longer and more
convoluted sentence structure inserting
unnecessary words and irrelevant but
factual sounding details in order to pad
the lie another president confronted
with the scandal proclaimed I can say
categorically that this investigation
indicates that no one on the White House
staff no one in this administration
presently employed was involved in this
very bizarre incident let's apply
linguistic analysis to some famous
examples take seven-time Tour de France
winner Lance Armstrong when comparing a
2005 interview in which he had denied
taking performance-enhancing drugs to a
2013 interview in which he admitted it
his use of personal pronouns increased
by nearly three quarters note the
contrast between the following two
quotes first okay you know a guy in a
French in a parisian laboratory opens up
your sample you know john frenzy so and
so and he tests it and then you get a
phone call from a newspaper that says we
found you to be positive six times for
EPO ii i lost myself in all of that i'm
sure there would be other people that
couldn't handle it but I certainly
couldn't handle it and I was used to
controlling everything in my life I
controlled every outcome in my life in
his denial Armstrong described a
hypothetical situation focused on
someone else removing himself from the
situation entirely in his admission he
owns his statements delving into his
personal emotions and motivations but
the use of personal pronouns is just one
indicator of deception let's look at
another example from former senator and
US presidential candidate John Edwards I
only know that the apparent father has
said publicly that he is the father of
the baby I also have not been engaged in
any activity of any description that
requested agreed to or supported
payments of any kind to the woman or to
the apparent father of the baby not only
is that
pretty long-winded way to say the baby
isn't mine but Edwards never calls the
other parties by name instead saying
that baby the woman and the apparent
father now let's see what he had to say
when later admitting paternity
I am Quinn's father I will do everything
in my power to provide her with the love
and support she deserves the statement
is shortened direct calling the child by
name and addressing his role in her life
so how can you apply these lie spotting
techniques to your life first remember
that many of the lies we encounter on a
daily basis are far less serious than
these examples and may even be harmless
but it's still worthwhile to be aware of
telltale clues like minimal self
references negative language simple
explanations and convoluted phrasing it
just might help you avoid an overvalued
stock an ineffective product or even a
terrible relationship